hi we're magma chamber paul jonathan
victoria and kevin and
this is alex
and he's a geometry teacher middle
school probably and uh he's a very good
teacher but like he's starting to lose
his students and he wants to find a way
to to get them more excited and fired up
this is jane jane is an architect who
wants to share her passion for building
and making
enter make matchmake which is a great
site to match up makers and educators
so we're going to
use our site to
take your profile information and allow
makers and educators to meet up online
and share material with the world
makers will be paired with educators
based on a couple different features so
you can sort by the amount of time you
have available resources like 3d
printers
standards like common core and gen
locality if you want to meet up in
person and skills like your profession
and stuff like that
okay so the site itself will have
project material both videos
step-by-step instruction uh and uh and
you'll be able to actually put new
projects up as you collaborate with
other people as well as remix old
projects uh you'll be able to also
select based on uh common core and
next-gen curriculum standards uh
different projects that cover different
areas and then we'll have also have
ratings and reviews of of material
that's not only been created by people
and reviewing each other but also people
who have used the same material that was
created by others we also have an
opportunity to make money on the site
and make it self-sustaining by selling
uh kits for the for classroom projects
uh sourcing materials is also uh
offering sponsorships for people to
sponsor classroom activities and at the
end of each collaboration people rate
each other and they rate uh materials
they use
ultimately alex was happy because his
students were now engaged and got to
build their dream houses and jane is
happy because she got to share her
passion with younger students
so there everybody's happy big thumbs up
all right slide to the left
who builds the pages
so um uh we thought we would actually do
some initial content development as a
lure as a bait kind of but uh but
essentially the the educators and the
makers uh and skilled people working
together would create projects
how are you going to create the need for
this in the education community the
buzz the idea is i think i think
project-based education is very much on
fire but uh but people don't know where
to start kind of and so uh we give them
some seed examples and then also by uh
offering guidance for tying it into core
curriculum standards uh then we're gonna
people will find a way to introduce it
into their classrooms so you call it
making but now you're talking about
project-based learning is it
project-based learning is it maker
education
do
it i mean it's a mix of both i mean the
makers and and when we were using a
broad term for makers i mean it could be
architects it could be crafts people it
could be jewelry makers it could be it
could be anything uh
artists uh things like that you know you
can do book binding with poetry in
english classes things like that
how do you adjust that with the current
governing structures so so i think if
you allow teachers to
figure out a way to justify it within
their requirements for covering material
they have some flexibility and then if
they don't then you can also offer it as
after school activities and things like
that
any other questions administrators how
would they react to this thing like that
so i i talked to uh uh
one of the founders of ten marks and one
of the things that they did is they they
got things up through the ground roots
the teachers start using it and then uh
eventually it gets adapted
all right let's give team 304 a round of
applause